[Music]
cortana all i need to know
is did we lose them i think we both know
the answer to that
we made a blind job how did that hear
first
the covenant ships have always been
faster as for tracking us all the way
from reach
at light speed my maneuvering options
were limited
we were running dark yes until we
decelerated
no one could have missed the hole we
tore in subspace
they were waiting for us on the far side
of the planet
so where do we stand our fighters are
mopping up the last of their recon
picket now nothing serious
but i've isolated approach signatures
for multiple ccs class battle groups
make it three capital ships per group
and in about 90 seconds they'll be all
over us
well that's it then bring the ship back
up to combat alert alpha
i want everyone at this station everyone
sir everyone
and cortana
let's give our old friends a warm
welcome i've already begun
all combat personnel
52 secure air locks on deck 11
you heard the lady move like you got a
purpose this is not a drill
i repeat this is not a grill
once again it is our job to finish with
the fly board starting
we are leaving this shipment and
engaging the covenant on solid ground
when we meet the enemy we will rip their
skulls from their spines
and toss them away laughing
am i right marines sir yes sir
damn right i am not moving out double
time
all you green horns who wanted to see
covenant up close
this is gonna be your lucky day
sir right let's thaw him out
okay bringing low-level systems online
cracking the case in 30 seconds
he's hot blowing the pins in five
[Music]
sorry for the quick thaw master chief
things are a little hectic right now
the disorientation should pass quickly
welcome back sir
we'll have you battle ready stat
chief please look around the room i need
to get a calibration reading for your
battle suits diagnostics
good thank you sir i'm bringing your
health monitors online sir
vital signs look normal no freezer burn
okay sir go ahead and climb out of the
cryo
i gave you a double dose of the wake up
stem take a quick walk around the cryo
bay and join me at the optical
diagnostic station when you're ready
stand on the red square please
okay sir look at me so we can begin i
know the ordinance techs usually take
care of your targeting sensors
but we're short of time chief just look
at each of the flashing panels to target
them
when you lock on it'll change color
okay that looks good sir i'm getting
some calibration errors
i'm going to invert your looking pitch
so you can see if you like it better
that way
try targeting the flashing lights again
is that better or should i switch it
back
okay try looking up and down again
please do you want me to leave it like
that or switch it again
okay i'll leave the pitch normal but if
you want you can change it yourself
later
i'm ready for the energy shield test now
please follow me to the energy shield
test station
fire teams report to defensive positions
alpha through sierra
sensors show inbound covenant boarding
craft stand by to repel borders
okay bring his energy shields online
please
all right shield read is fully charged
okay sir bring them down to test the
automatic recharge
recharging normally we're showing green
across the board
bridge to cryo 2 this is captain key
send the master chief to the bridge
immediately
captain we'll have to skip the weapons
diagnostics
aye aye sir the skipper seems jumpy we
better get moving
we'll find your weapons later okay i'll
leave the self diagnostics running at
least
good idea you'd better get to your evac
group sam affirmative
i just have to reset the computer and
i'm out of here oh god they're trying to
get through the door
security
come on we've got to get the hell out of
here
this way
oh
asap over here
captain keys
good to see you master chief things
aren't going well
cortana did her best but we never really
had a chance
a dozen covenant superior battleships
against a single halcyon class cruiser
with those odds i'm content with three
make them four
kills sleep well
no thanks to your driving yes
it must have been one of their boarding
parties i'd guess an anti-matter charge
bam fire control for the main cannon is
offline
captain the cannon was my last defensive
option all right
i'm initiating coal protocol for
abandoning the auto
that means you too cortana while you do
what go down with the ship
in a matter of speaking the object we
found i'm gonna try and land the autumn
on it
with all due respect sir this war has
enough dead
heroes i appreciate your concern cortana
but it's not up to me
protocol is clear destruction or capture
of a shipboard ai is absolutely
unacceptable and that means you're
leaving [ __ ]
lock in a selection of emergency landing
zones upload them to my neural lace
and then sort yourself for a heart
transfer aye sir
get cortana off this ship keep her safe
from the enemy
if they capture her they'll learn
everything forced deployment weapons
research
earth i understand
the autumn will continue evasive
maneuvers until you initiate a landing
sequence
not that you'll listen but i'd suggest
letting my sub routines handle the final
approach
excellent work thank you are you ready
yank me
good luck master
your architecture isn't much different
from the autumns
don't get any funny ideas
i don't keep it loaded
oh
those marines oh use some help chief do
what you do best
follow me carefully i lost
hey that's the way to do it
[Applause]
did something just hit us
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rap
they're using our lifeboat airlocks to
attach their boarding craft
we go out and they come in clever
bastards
run away
[Music]
foreign
above us
put your head down
oh
i'm going after him
oh
life pods are launching
we have to use the ship's maintenance
access ways follow the nav point it will
lead you to an opening
[Music]
[Music]
i'm detecting covenant movement outside
the access race
activating motion tracker
we're too close we need to find another
route motion tracker shows all clear
wait we need to get through that
[Applause]
[Music]
it looks like the covenant
alright
combat teams alpha through november pull
out the nearest
i see one
[Music]
[Music]
moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get aboard before it launches
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
now would be a very good time to leave
punches
we're gonna make it aren't we sir i
don't wanna die out here
look
[Music]
what is that thing lieutenant yeah
i still had fingers they'd be crossed
[Music]